no angel investing vaynermedia and also
he recently want to pay your artistry
ventures so how to bounce that their
personal lives making life right yeah no
question and the thing that I'm most
struggle with this work life balance no
question it is a constant battle and I
never like giving advice on it because
the truth is I kind of attack that early
on on my first date with my wife about
20 minutes in when I'm like holy crap
you marry this girl
I started in that date communicating
that I love my little chance and I don't
understand like you know they literally
on our second date we had a very like
real conversation I'm like you think
this is like we got married in a year
move very quickly clearly on our second
date I was like you're gonna think one
day we're gonna have kids found with a
mellow out I just need you to understand
that everything that goes by I don't own
the Jets I'm gonna become less stressed
more not less and so the truth is I
spent a lot of time communicating with
my partner inviting out late I don't
know if her dad was successful guides
traveled a lot in corporate America so
you should have appetite for that
because so much data points to like what
your dad does allows you to like
reconcile that I over communicated over
the you negated now here's where I'm
struggling it's all worked great the
most part it's all very hard to
vayner/rse the $25 fun being a big walk
around we're not reasons to get real
serious
vaynermedia's down to 20 to 400
employees in the last 20 months and I've
operated that so busy ship there all the
other things I'm involved in nonprofit
boards which I'm pretty tired of like
that kind of part of my life speaking
and writing books are come very very
very busy every minute is that
every day I are basically programmed
from 6 a.m. to 11 p.m. every there's not
a single day Monday through Friday that
I get home outside of this time
University Jewish holidays bracket home
before 11 p.m. I was like my waiter like
one of extremities Monday through Friday
I'm not Saturdays I think all in how to
get on the phone and big now start
taking six seven weeks of vacation which
is up from two and so we figured out we
hacked but that's just us communicating
there's no I can't give that advice to
other people we're not getting caught as
me show my daughter's there at 5:00 they
are one of us too so here we go to the
next chapter right that ballet recital
is she she's got Debbie's the event she
wants to be in front of people he's
going to be into you know they're
starting to become real people like I
was like I knew the beginning is gonna
be easy for me because I'm super
non-existent brother
my kids about to have to be and so my
brother's 11 years younger than me and
we were very kind of brotherly fatherly
relationship and that happened with my
brother my sister always talks about
like how she spent every minute with him
from like zero to four and then I got a
bomb it was gone and so I'm now already
starting to think about what's gonna be
my new hat I prioritize my health
recently only for the last 75 days and I
perfectly had work out every day I hired
a full-time employee to babysit me
that's how I happen you know it's it's
obnoxious and I hate saying it out loud
because it makes me eat me but the only
way I was gonna take care of my house
and that's but kill you keep happy with
I thought was the busiest guy of all
time there wasn't a minute to spare you
know 90 days ago and now I'm working out
for an hour every single day somehow and
so clearly it's manageable so the real
answer is effort it's you know I really
think it's effort and being flexible
back to like what I said to you earlier
on the photonic stuff like I'm a counter
pleasure I react that gene makes me good
entrepreneur it's also make me a happy
guy because I'm able to turn on a dime
and say okay this is not working anymore
we should is playing field hockey and
have some psychosis and I have to leave
at 2 o'clock in the afternoon sometimes
and so I have to change the way I work